Bonjour à tous
Alors aujourd'hui vidéo exceptionnelle
Je réserve une surprise à mon pote YouTuber Jhon Rachid
On va lui faire rencontrer son idole
Jean-Claude Van Damme !
Il en sait rien, il croit que c'est un Making-Off je lui ai rien dit
C'est que du vrai
NO FAKE !
Je sais pas ce que ça va être parce que là
Il est un petit peu malade il a pas envie de venir
On va essayer de le motiver,  j'espère que ça va marcher Let's go
*rire*
Ça va ?
Ouais !
Bah y a les caméras
Oh bah alors !
C'est parti pour le making-off
Tu voulais me surprendre ?
Tu prends tes affaires on y va ?
Bon c'est parti pour un "making-off" avec Jhon Rachid !
Si on s'endort par contre peut-être enlève tes chaussons
Quoi ? C'est des chausson Dragon Ball qu'est ce qu'il y a ?
Et bien là je vais t'emmener pour l'instant dans ce véhicule
Comme dans les films d'actions
Ferme ta gueule tu rentres !
En fait je t'ai menti
Là c'est pas un making-off qu'on tourne
On te résérve une ENORME surprise
Mais c'est quoi ce délire là ?
*rire*
Je t'ai dit qu'on ferait qu'un plan dans la voiture et que après ce serai terminé
Mais c'est totalement faux !
AH !
Il faut y aller en voiture
Et la surprise elle est là-bas
Et c'est vraiment un truc de ouf
Te connaissant je sais que si jamais
Tu le fais pas tu vas regretter TOUTE ta vie
Bah go hein mais tu sais ce que c'est tu peux me donner des indices ?
Ok monsieur, LET'S GO !
Faut savoir que j'étais dans mon lit tranquille
Et que cet homme m'a dit : T'inquiète pas ça prend 2s
Sauf que j'ai une putain de grippe
Si vous saviez comment je suis grippé
J'ai des courbatures partout
J'ai même pas pris d'Eferalgan
Une fois que tu seras face à la surprise
Tout ça va être oublié en une fraction de seconde
C'est sûr !
Par contre c'est très très bien joué !
On va faire un making-off de ma vidéo de Noël
Et puis j'ai même pas réfléchit en me disant :
Mais à quel moment y a un making-off quand on tourne pas en fait ?
Franchement
Je crois que ça fait plus de 6 mois qu'on prépare ça
On va prendre les mouchoirs hein, pour quand il va pleurer
On est devant un hôtel
Ouais !
Bah ce que je te propose c'est d'aller dans cet hôtel
Je veux bien te suivre mais je suis en stress là !
Allez c'est parti !
Attention
J'ai la pression comme jamais !
C'est n'importe quoi !
J'ai mon coeur qui bat pour rien
Mais non t'inquiète
pour aucune raison, je ne sais pas ce que je vais faire
Qu'est ce que je fais ?
Je rentre directement ici ?
Donc là on est dans une pièce de l'hôtel
En train d'attendre la surprise
Et je vous cache pas que la tension est totale
Mon coeur il bat frère !
C'est n'importe quoi votre délire là !
Même moi je sais la surprise
Même moi j'ai les mains moites
Non mais en plus vraiment
C'est toute l'équipe avec lesquelles on bosse tout le temps
Y a Antoine Barillot par exemple avec qui j'ai fait Jour de pluie etc
Et je vois que des gueules que je connais
Et depuis tout à l'heure ils sont tous comme ça :
*rire*
Est-ce que tu sais qu'il y aura un avant et un après ce moment
C'est à dire que là tu peux noter ce jour
Comme un jour HISTORIQUE dans ta vie !
Oh putain ! La il me faut une verveine là !
Attend vous me faites monter le stress encore plus
ARRÊTE DE FAIRE ÇA !
Ça me fait stresser encore plus !
*soupir*
ARRÊTE !
T'es relou de ouf tu verras toi
Je suis pas bien là !
Ah mais t'es chiant !
Je te jure tu me fais vraiment monter un truc alors arrête !
Oh putaaaain !
J'ai la diarrhée là !
Oh putain arrête tes conneries là !
*Toc toc*
Hellooo
Oh laaaa
Ça va ?
C'EST INCROYABLE !
C'es magnifique !
T'es en forme ?
Ça va ?
Qu'est ce que je suis content !
Norman ?
Oui !
Comment ça va ?
Enchanté !
Ça va ?
Ouais super !
Qu'est ce que je suis content !
Moi aussi
C'est incroyable c'est pas possible
C'est pas possible
Ah vous me rendez euh
Non non la c'est ..
I'm shy
Là c'est le plus gros truc de ma vie là !
C'est son rêve !
Ça c'est le rêve de ma vie là
Merci beaucoup
T'es le meilleur au monde !
Non non non..
Si si ! T'es le meilleur c'est sûr !
Ça c'est Youtube c'est ça ?
Ça c'est Youtube ouais !
Alors en gros moi je m'appelle Norman
Je suis Youtuber
Jhon c'est aussi un Youtuber et on est poto
On vit ensemble en coloc
Et il te voue un culte depuis des années
Oui
Il est fan de toi, moi aussi
Mais alors lui c'est gigantesque
Je te connais par coeur !
Et Jhon il a fait des parodies de toi
Enfin pas des parodies mais comme des publicités façon Van Damme
Les fausses pubs de Jean-Claude
Jhon Rachid the pote of Van Damme
I'm gonna see right now
Gilette en partenariat avec Jean-Claude Van Damme
Ont mêlés l'art du Nunchaku et l'art du rasoir
Pour créer :
Le Nunchasoir
C'est super bien réalisé
Le Nunchakarasoir !
C'est le Nuncharasoir c'est ça ?
Nunchasoir !
Super !
Mais je savais pas !
Maintenant je vais être abonner
Merci merci !
On se met à trois là regardez
Vas-y vient !
Voilà maintenant on est pote ensemble !
Toi va te mettre là-bas deux secondes !
Et voilà !
Il faut que tu viennes sur mon prochain tournage hein
Ouais ouais ouais avec Norman !
Avec plaisir
Quand tu veux
On fait un truc sympa
Je peux te :
OUI !
Non non non mieux t'es mon poto on va faire un truc bien !
On protège un truc comme ça
Vas-y vas-y vas-y c'est quand tu veux où tu veux
Han y a Mohamed Qissi !
Come here
Attends deux secondes je vais te faire plaisir
Mets toi là et moi ici deux secondes
Jhon est un très grand fan de nous
AH OUI !
Et ça c'est Norman
Voilà euh, bonsoir ça va ?
Super !
T'es rassuré ou pas ?
Ouais ça va
Allez fais des petits coups de poing de gauche à droite
Contre Tong Po
Je suis en train de me battre contre Tong Po là !
Vas-y Momo vas-y !
Oh my god !
Incroyable !
Moi j'ai vu de derrière ça a bien frolé
Merci Mohamed
Tu veux que je te mette un coup de pied aussi ?
Bah avec plaisir !
Allez viens
J'attends que ça !
Vas-y Norman !
Toi tu te mets la t'es la victime
Ah bah parfait
Tu te mets en garde
Met ton bras en avant que je te pète pas ton bras
T'es prêt ?
Oui
One, two
Ouaww
Ça va?
Momo vient ici avec nous !
J'ai senti le vent sur mon visage
voilà maintenant t'es coiffé !
Oh la la y a Mohamed Qissi, y a tout le monde c'est incroyable !
Est-ce que tu as vu "Jean Van Johnson" ?
Oui j'ai vu le premier episode
Tu m'as fait beaucoup rire
T'as pas peur de rire de toi
Non !
Et même dans les JCVD y avait déjà la mise en abime un petit peu
où tu parlais de toi plus intimement
C'est pas que du karaté
c'est pas que du combat
c'est pas une série d'action
Enfin même si il y a de l'action
C'est aussi très drôle
Action
J'adore l'eau
Mais dans 30 ans il y en aura plus
Oui je l'ai eu en face !
Alors en tout cas moi je suis très content d'avoir pu organiser
un petit peu ce match, cette rencontre
Je suis un peu ému indirectement parce que je sais à quel point il est fan de toi, fan de vous
Jhon t'es un mec super je t'adore frère vraiment
C'est toi le meilleur vraiment
Vraiment c'est toi le meilleur tu viens de réaliser le plus beau jour de ma vie la maintenant
Franchement c'est magnifique
Mohamed je te remercie beaucoup
Merci mon frère
Et à mon romain aussi
OUI NORMAN !
Romain bonsoir
Norman !
Je suis désolée fais moi un gros bisous mon poto
Je sais pas ce qu'il vient de se passer là
Il en tremble encore un peu là
Écoute je suis content d'avoir fait ça
Ça faisait tellement longtemps que je voulais te faire réaliser ce rêve !
Et est-ce que il est comme tu l'imaginais ?
Il est mieux que ce que j'imaginais !
Enfin ça se voit
Il partage, il donne, il est sincère, il est vrai
Et c'est Jean-Claude Van Damme
Est-ce que on peut le dire on est transparent
Cette rencontre t'aurait été absolument impossible
Sans l'aide de Amazon Prime Video
Oui parce qu'il sort sa série la dessus donc pour sa promo
On en a profité
Et tant mieux !
En tout cas si les gens ont appréciés cette video ils peuvent mettre un petit :
Tumb to the top
Et on oublie jamais :
L'eau, dans 20 ou 30 ans
Y en aura plus
MERCI LA VIE !